Husband pulled the muscles in his neck and stretched his nerves as well. What program would be
helpful to run? He has been to a carpractor and it has been two years. Okay, so two years since
he had this injury and it's not getting better. Oh, then would the rife be helpful? Well, sure,
then rife can be helpful. I would say accelerated healing. I would say inflammation. There may be other
precipitating comorbidities that is hindering healing process. So if you're talking about your neck,
if there was, you know, sometimes you have to go to a different carpractor too. So if you're going
to the same carpractor, you're not getting good results. In carpractor, there's a lot of different
techniques. So you may have to find somebody who uses a technique that actually
is analyzing your spine and correcting things instead of just making adjustments.
So you might have to look for a different type of carpractor. Other other therapies that could
be used, tens unit, for sure, I would think. But again, try to get to the diagnosis of what the cause is.
So I don't know, I don't remember who asked this question. So I don't know how old your husband would
be, but definitely as we age, you can have degenerative joint disease. And then if you
damage your neck, you get some sort of twisted action or car accident or something like that.
You could have damage to the joint capsules themselves and arthritic changes that go along with that. So
looking at other things as well as muscular skeletal things could be helpful.
So as far as the rif goes, I would say accelerated healing and I would say inflammation,
try the pain programs. If you want to have them set up, again, I don't remember who this was,
but if you want to have them set up a consult with me, I may have some other suggestions to look at as
well if I get a little bit more information.